what's up guys welcome back to the Daily
Dropout I'm Danny today I'm going to be
asking girls how much money should a guy
make per year
real quick how much should a guy make
per year what depends
depends on how many kids he has and a
couple two three million I think that's
fair all right
take a guess 150
150 I'm gonna say 250 200.
[Music]
I have no clue like a million two
million
okay we're at ASU you know so you're not
gonna find him here and no wonder at ASU
this is this is how wait wait just just
for my own understanding is this how
young girls walk around on college
campuses just like that like that in
Arizona they do that's how they go to
class and things wait like this yeah
yeah
okay
oh goodness I gotta move out there oh
yeah yeah I mean I know I went to
college in the in the 19th century but
still this is a million dollars this
chick said walking around with their
bellies all exposed and their boobies
exposed you're always supposed to pick
one body part by the way for the ladies
in your life or any ladies watching if
you wear a short skirt you got to wear a
more modest top if you wear a bimbo
shirt you better have the bottom cover
and you'll have everything all hanging
out at once and you look like
this like fully like adult she just said
four words and two of them were like
someone that you you consider wanting to
be with the rest of your life 300 okay
three figures that's close Okay so why
is that
it's because like that's a stable income
I'd say 100 like 500 I'd say like a
thousand bucks a year that's stable
no that's 500 is
like so that's this is just a perfect
example of the complete lack of
financial literacy and understanding
it's not our country is that this is a
grown girl who's old enough to go to
college join join the military do a lot
of things and she doesn't even know if
500 000 is a lot or decent income or not
it's funny that they're all independent
chicks but you're asking them what does
your man need to make like you're not
gonna ever go up to a man and say what
does your woman need to make that's just
not a question yes it is it sure is
among softing men who rely on their
women to run their lives yeah the blue
pilled men
a lot more expensive yeah Mills Millions
Mills [__] okay I don't really at least
they were at least kidding around
Millions
smells what percentage of people make a
million a year we've seen a lot of girls
asking for Millions despite only about
0.1 percent of Americans making over a
million a year so if only 0.1 percent of
Americans make a million a year and
that's what these girls demand that
would mean that they should be and
around the top 0.1 percent of women and
some of those 0.1 are women so it
Narrows the pool even no I know that's
what I said around it would
realistically be like 0.2 interesting
here I think I mean I like when guys
like pay for dates and stuff so if a guy
made 30k a year is that something you're
okay with yeah I think that would be
great like your husband oh [__]
husband yeah I think that would be fine
if it was my husband I'd be in love with
him
I wouldn't really say it you better be
really in love because you're going to
be broke
no more paying for days I mean it's you
know I don't want to make fun of people
that are that aren't making a lot of
money because you know what's crazy
that's like about the median income but
that's like the median income is 30 000
which is it's just a mind [__] it's just
sad that these girls are adults and they
really have no idea what it takes to
live because so many college students
are tricked into thinking that money is
just like a like this abstract thing
that doesn't really matter and they all
signed off on 200 and 300 000 loans to
go to school well money is a fugazi but
not in the way that they think so they
just don't understand anything about it
but realistically it's crazy you haven't
said that in a while I like it so crazy
fugazi is a wizzy it's a woozy money
isn't real minimum six figures no matter
what the situation is we have an
expensive lifestyle yeah no I mean I
totally understand we got to get good
skin care routine you know the whole
whole nine yards
no man it's it's gonna be weird when I
have a girlfriend and she's going I need
money for my skin care I'm gonna be like
[__] off there's no way your wife the
thought of my wife take care of her skin
but unless unless she's wife material
she should be asking you money for
anything I've never had to give girls
money like if this chick was like I'm
expensive like [__] no you shouldn't be
giving a girl money for anything unless
you know you're gonna wipe her up and
she wants to marry you and you're
treating her to things you're giving her
gifts she likes skincare give her a spa
day you know but get out of the house
she's paying all her bills I don't get
that I can't see your circumstance in
which that would be okay
120k all right what the [__] are these
girls smoking that they all want a guy
making six figures what percent of
people make six figures five percent
half of these girls demand guys worth
six figures and they all think they're
tens like what kind of world like what
kind of delusional world do we live in
this is madness
oh these girls
sock money and buy and buy a home and
invest or invest in no hate markets or
in land or in real estate even the fours
you're gonna get mad but even the fours
are I mean I guess I guess I don't have
a matter what you look like because
that's what no no just stop everybody's
got their match as they say there's an
ask for a receipt I'm sure if you looked
at the statistics as girls get better
looking the men that they marry make
more money women fought for their right
to go to college and they're like I
can't do my eyelashes before my basic
lit class no
um I'm planning on just like supporting
myself
with my income so he's really pretty
plan on being supported by the person
that I'm dating what is the lowest you
would go though
um
500 000.
I could have a like a nice like subtle
life with like
like a thousand a year like
lowest though
200 isn't too much to ask for it's not
it's not as crazy as you should be
reaching for that the girl that wants
Millions all right well you better
really make sure that you're stepping it
up so that you're worthy of that would
you be comfortable with making more
money than your guy or no
um probably not no I don't want him to
rely on me if he's still working and
making money then I don't think it
really would matter if you're both
putting work in the guy who's talking to
told me women shouldn't be working so
now with a hole so they're crazy stats
of when the girl makes more the divorce
like the the relationship just goes to
[__] I heard somebody
in some kind of podcast I can't remember
we've never heard it but I I didn't look
it up to see if it's true or what the
other surrounding stats are but if that
is true that sounds right that's really
sad
whole thing right you got like four dogs
ten kids
uh 10 kids is a stretch no pun intended
that was disgusting okay well I'm
expecting to make a lot of money so okay
I'm okay with like carrying it so you're
down to be the breadwinner yeah no I
wouldn't mind if I was making I feel
like that's just a level of delusion not
not even like she seems like a nice girl
like I don't think it's male intent or
anything but I just think once you're in
that relationship and you are the
breadwinner I don't think that that's
that's gonna fly she's also a good
looking girl I doubt she'd even end up
ever being with a guy that makes less
than her you never know man yeah but the
thing is it's like to an extent it's
like if she's dating unless she's making
crazy money it's like if she's dating a
loser then yeah because you know a lot
of success does correlate to how much
money you make I haven't seen a
relationship where the woman makes more
and I know several where the woman makes
more where it's a really happy
relationship but I I don't think that's
the one thing that is messing with that
relationship there's a lot of things
there I'm sure it's not husband's got to
get on his [__] I'm sure it's not
helping no I wouldn't mind if I was
making more money as long as they're
making a lot I think we both need to be
rich then we can now both have a really
nice lifestyle this February we're
partnering up with a Navy SEAL friend of
ours Tom Shea host a 21 day virtual
event that you guys can join with us Tom
is going to teach you how to listen to
your mind in a new way and how to
control it so that you can have the
discipline you need to build the life
you want whether it's working out your
relationships your money your spiritual
growth this is a 21 day virtual event
where you get to learn how to kill the
excuses in your head and you get to
learn some discipline and those are
things that's how successful people get
successful best part is when you come in
through us you get a discount on the
enrollment so use code Sunny fast50 to
get 50 off the event you will not regret
it you will be a changed person at the
end of it do not miss this so if you're
interested in becoming a reformed human
an absolute animal go to tomshay.com and
use Sunny fast50 for 50 off of this
program I mean do you care about how he
would make his money like real estate
job versus you know a male stripper
I guess
Haram money like just railing chicks on
only fans you'd be fine with that you
know what I was talking about with my
friend he was talking about how in Islam
it talks about Dirty Money like bad
money and good money I don't know if it
talks about that in the Bible at all but
how when you have dirty money it only
brings like poison into your life and it
doesn't end up doing you any good so
it's not even worth it to strive for
that stuff because it doesn't bring you
any good but when you earn your money
the right way then it's actually more
beneficial to you that's interesting
less good money is more beneficial than
more bad money I think that makes sense
I don't know what the Bible says about
that specifically but I know that the
Bible says that we are you know that God
provides for us and he sees us as
stewards of his money so how we spend it
is uh you know determines our
relationship with God so I think it
there's definitely a correlation between
those two thoughts I think that's really
true though I definitely agree well
would happen if you
know started dating this guy and he told
you that he had a lot of money whatever
and then you later found out he was
broke
I'd leave him he's a liar and he's broke
I leave he has like no motivation to fix
it or he's like I've been selling feet
picks non-stop on my only fans and I'm I
swear to God I will be making 100K by
the end of the year
I know someone that does that like I'll
be like blackmail him did she just
insinuate that that's what she does
who's paying for feet picks you know
what I don't understand is this whole
Market because only fans is a billion
dollar market and I don't know
apparently anyone that's ever bought an
only fan so people are lying people are
lying there's just straight cappers out
there maybe it's this guy right here
he's the one out here buying them all
buying up all the only fan accounts yeah
I don't know who's buying them I'm not
it's just so depressing to think of all
the potential that human beings are born
with and all the things that we could
accomplish and there are people just in
their rooms playing with themselves
looking at other people's feet oh my God
yeah not even the feet like we just
squander everything we just squander
every minute of Our Lives we're
disgusting we don't ugh please the sun
just needs to blow up already probably
like blackmail him maybe cry a bit
week is dick pics
really yeah okay yeah bear down but the
men here way hotter and all the guys
there are [__]
okay is that what you're that's you
talking [__]
no I'm just I someone's mother one day
will that's all I gotta say he's in
Teague yeah [__] you will and teak do
you guys care about how oh I hate girl
the Frack the frat girls who love frat
guys that's like my biggest pet peeve in
girls we're going to see up on Friday
yeah that was lame if you will it take
oh my God Theta Kai boys
so cringe like what is that what is it
about like because you you go after like
a certain threat like what just doesn't
make sense to me I think it's just code
for being a hoe oh he makes his money
you know because if he's making good
money does it matter what he's doing
specifically to make that money
definitely matters that's why you don't
tell girls how you make your money stay
mysterious she's cute any any final
thoughts on I know I was also an
airheaded idiot in college most of the
time so I try hard not to judge but I
really just wish we did a better p a
better job of raising and educating
people so that they weren't quite as
stupid at this age because because
watching these conversations makes me
sad yeah you know before the the
generation before me uh women at that
age were running homes raising kids some
of them many of them were also working
and now with that age in the late teens
early 20s everyone's just a
self-absorbed nitwit who can't even who
doesn't even understand basic things
like how much a hundred thousand dollars
a year ago is that it is crazy to think
that annoys me what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do all right thank
you Aaron's fault thanks for watching if
you liked the video please drop a sub
give it a like drop us off give it all
okay look for sunny and me on Instagram
all right thank you guys for watching
I'll see you later
[Music]
won't last long yeah the feelings